the first ten minutes of Ori and the
blind forest are emotionally devastating
it is a phenomenal opening a short end
wordless tale featuring two expressive
characters who clearly have great
affection for each other and from here
the game builds a poignant story a
gorgeous world and a wonderful adventure
on the surface or in the blind forest is
a lot like other platformers gating your
progress behind doors that can only be
open once you have learned a particular
skill as the nimble creature Ori you
leap and flit about with fantastic grace
and as or ease abilities improve so do
the joys of movement Ori responds
wonderfully to subtle movements of the
analog stick allowing you to finesse him
into exactly the right place when you
earn your double jump or a somersaults
like an acrobat and reacts in midair to
your after touch the controls are spot
on making it always fun to leap through
this vibrant world one by one you'll
learn new skills and new challenges
arrive with them Ori can fire energy
orbs of enemies and those creatures can
be difficult to overcome
you must take advantage of or ease
dexterity by leaping over exploding
pustules jumping from wall to wall or
putting the other abilities you have to
good use for instance you can deflect
projectiles aiming the projectiles one
way while flinging yourself in the
opposite direction propelling yourself
through the sky becomes one of Orion the
blind forests most vital moves in time
you launch or a through dangerous places
using fiery orbs and hovering crows that
midair fling is at the heart of one of
the game's most thrilling scenes a
difficult escape from rising water that
will drown you if you make a mistake the
trial and error this scene and others
require can prove frustrating but what a
feeling it is to overcome the challenge
the tightly timed retreats that close
each chapter are among the finest
moments in any platformer released in
recent years if for a were clumsy or if
these sequences weren't timed so
precisely the moments would be simply
annoying but in Orion the blind forest
each element harmonizes so well with
every other those exciting escapes are
complemented by moments of pure bliss or
can break his fall with a leafy
parachute when you're gliding through
the air it's easy to appreciate the
game's visual artistry multiple layers
give each environmental lovely sense of
depth it isn't just the vibrant art that
makes Horry in the blind forest feel
like a fairy tale it's also the story
which is told to you through English
subtitles accompanied by a narrator who
chants along in an unknown language it's
a simple fable about the renewal of a
ravaged land but it's the details that
make it so enchanting the characters are
so expressive and the plot developments
so sincere that you'll grow to care
about this lovely place the game isn't
just lovely it's also quite clever it
consistently surprises you with new
tricks changes in gravity new ways to
move through its paces and carefully
design levels that require you to think
quickly and respond this all occurs in a
single interconnected world that's hard
not to fall in love with or in the blind
forest is fun and fantastical and after
12 hours of exploring I was heartbroken
when it came to a close
rest assured however I will be returning